the right motor take to make a great
world class app today on one platform
you know calm calm or Evernote whatever
I mean just just scope out the 1.0 what
is the number of collaborators number of
months to sort of get a solid 1.0 to
market on one platform these days so
hopefully what we do which isn't which
isn't everything but we have a pretty
tight filter on this so we we build
things that we can get to market in a
mainstream way in 12 to 18 months okay
so we're just not set up it would be
inefficient for us to do five year
science projects because we have a lot
of like we're reusing a lot of people we
have a lot of experts that we have
dedicated people for each project with
them we also have people that rotate
amongst projects as they're needed ah
like a product manager or designer
there were like IP lawyers and writers
and editors and user testers exactly and
then there's there's court dedicated
team so everything we do is we try to
when it launches launch it at a high
production value so like it doesn't feel
like startup stuff it feels good it's
thoughtful it's like it's professional I
like the concept of taking out the 50%
of what you spend in the first year that
has nothing to do with a product 90% no
come on like when we invest in things
right just when we invest I mean like me
personally and you as an investor in
startups like you know sprinters like
how much of the time when they're asking
us for advice are they asking about like
what really matters which is the product
versus how much of the time are they
asking about oh how do I fill out this
round how do I fire my co-founder how do
I deal with board drop yeah how do we do
all this contract that's the hard stuff
yeah I put it at 5050 I think they spend
like half their time trying to raise
money and hire people and then they
maybe can put their head down for 30
hours a week
yeah and build product I think it's more
but but you he's pretty good amount so
so we talked about you unlock 30 hours
of product I mean it's basically what
you're saying and we and a lot of it is
we have people that startups don't know
exists right so for example atever know
right and Evernote the night before
we're gonna launch it I launched the
free in the premium version the same
time so we had you know it was a
freemium model so we had the premium
version on day one the night before we
were going to launch it I remember
that's like 3:00 a.m. that I forgot to
decide how much to charge for the
premium version mmm didn't set a price
yeah that would be an oversight yeah
premium yeah so you know you sound like
Apple News plus yeah before Apple
streaming they're like you're gonna love
it yeah here's some celebrities we don't
have a prices Disney yesterday's like
seven dollars yet so we so we had to
pick a price so I you know I called up
some co-founders and we had a you know a
hurry discussion in the middle of the
night and we think it was five bucks a
month that's what we picked because we
were ill I was like you know science it
was like four bucks a month seems cheap
six bucks a month sounds expensive
Proxima yeah and we did not change that
price for six years right and for six
years I knew that we had the wrong price
because I remember picking it at random
at 3 a.m. so I knew the right to my
chances of having that be the correct
price or zero yeah but we didn't know
how to do pricing and in those six years
by then you know we had we had a be test
that everything else like a million
times because we were good at that but
we didn't know we didn't have pricing
experts because pricing experts don't
hang out at startups so six years later
we finally hired the first person to it
that actually understood how to do
pricing and I thought it was boring but
when I was explained to me how to do it
actually it's actually fascinating so
now I'm kind of a pricing expert and
then we started experimenting the
pricing and we basically doubled our
revenue without changing the product mix
within eighteen months just by being
smart about pricing I've never met a
startup that understands pricing theory
but a hundred percent of products that
are released ought to have gone through
a pricing size before they're released
so now we have people that do that for
all of our stuff yeah
same thing with IP we have a dedicated
staff that's like think about what Pixar
did they're talking to and they talks
about this in creativity creativity Inc
the person who's writing the story is
going to a meeting with people who have
made all the other movies and they're
sitting in a room with fifteen people
talking about the different acts a
different character development and
they're getting candid feedback and
that's the word he uses yeah on it so
just that candid feedback I think it's
gonna work you look at so another myth
so I do a lot of work overseas most of
our business actually international and
even with Evernote that was the case and
so I hear a lot of myths about Silicon
Valley and one of them is that Silicon
Valley is really good because we know
how to fail efficiently like oh my god
no we don't like startups do not fail
efficiently yeah
like if I'm gonna be a first-time
starter founder and I get out of you
know YC and I raise the three million
dollar seed like a million dollars into
it I could have convinced myself there's
a stupid idea but I'm gonna try to stay
alive yeah so I'm gonna spend three
million and then I'm gonna go back to my
investors and get a bridge so I could
have failed for a million dollars but
I'm probably gonna waste five million to
fail it's very capital and efficient and
it's very emotionally inefficient
because there's all these people very
talented people working and Walking Dead
startups that everyone knows or knowing
so who fails well Netflix HBO you know
HBO Netflix they make hundreds of pilots
a year yeah the pilots are very much
like startups the very innovative their
combined team they worked really hard
nine months 12 months whatever it takes
a hundred percent of the pilots are
technically excellent your HBO pilot
will not fail because you use the wrong
cameras and ran out of budget and got
into a fight with a caterers yeah they
know how to do that they don't make the
amateur mistakes yeah so you don't know
what the wrong lens on yeah I don't put
the lens on back right which is exactly
why most startups fail right most
failures have nothing to do with their
product they fail because they're
pricing or they don't know customer had
how to talk to customers they don't know
anything right except hopefully their
one things which are brilliant at but
you can't just know one thing you have
to know a thousand things